une rentrée sans pression sans cartable
et sans classe depuis 3 ans manael fait
l'école à la maison ses parents se sont
pliés à sa volonté ils préfèrent
apprendre aux côtés de sa mère ça te
manque l'école ça nous manque pas ça me
manque pas c'est pas que j'aime pas
apprendre
j'aime bien la prendre
mais j'aime pas l'école on commence
généralement l'instruction vers 9h on va
faire du formal pendant une heure une
heure et demie ça va être français Matt
donc les matières fondamentales après
ben on est libre on va vers ce qui fait
plaisir et ce qui fait plaisir à son
fils en cette période de rentrée ce sont
les cours de géographie
sur la carte oui ici durant trois ans
manael est allé à l'école mais il n'a
pas supporté la vie en collectivité à la
fin du CP ses parents donc choisi de
l'instruire à la maison sa mère a même
arrêté de travailler pour se consacrer à
son enseignement en fait on a eu trois
maîtresses différentes
ça a été très dur pour moi j'arrivais
plus à suivre parce qu'il y a trop de
bruit il y a trop d'enfants ça lui
donnait tellement d'efforts pendant la
journée
car à 16h30 c'était l'apocalypse on
avait des crises non-stop jusqu'au
lendemain matin mais depuis deux ans les
règles se sont durci avant une simple
déclaration des parents suffisait
désormais il faut obtenir une
autorisation de l'éducation nationale
avec plusieurs motifs la santé ou le
handicap de l'enfant une activité
sportive ou artistique intensive et
l'itinérance géographique le quatrième
critère est plus flou il mentionne
seulement la situation de l'enfant et le
projet éducatif privilégié par de
nombreuses familles il pose problème
tout dépend des inspecteurs de
l'éducation nationale et d'un dossier
très détaillé le petit frère de manael
vient d'être refusé ils viennent à la
maison ils viennent voir nos enfants ils
viennent faire des contrôles donc
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire de plus pour
prouver que qu'on fait bien les choses
en fait l'an dernier 5000 dossiers ont
ainsi été refusés des décisions que les
familles contestent d'autant que le taux
de refus varie en fonction des
départements mais pour ce directeur
d'académie ces nouvelles règles étaient
nécessaires
combien de temps l'enfant est-il
confronté aux apprentissages qui
assurent son instruction est-ce que
cette personne elle est compétences
requises est-ce que les personnes qui
interviennent auprès de l'enfant parle
suffisamment le français il fallait
professionnaliser tout ça cette réforme
a été votée dans le cadre de la loi
contre les séparatismes afin de lutter
contre la radicalisation même si dans
les faits peu de familles sont
concernées sur les quelques 53 000
enfants qui pratiquent l'école à la
maison la proportion de famille
éventuellement radicalisée n'est pas
nulle mais marginal voire exceptionnel
toutes les études montrent que ça
correspond à des démarches de parents et
à des profils sociaux de parents
extrêmement différents dans les familles
qui pratiquent l'instruction à la maison
la révolte gronde parmi celles qui se
sont rassemblé pour un pique-nique à
l'occasion de la rentrée certaines ont
même décidé d'entrer en résistance je
refuse de demander l'autorisation à
l'état l'État n'est pas mon papa donc
nous on continuera l'instruction en
famille quoi qu'il arrive en
désobéissance civile dans un an plus de
dérogations possibles les familles
devront toutes présenter un dossier afin
d'obtenir l'autorisation d'enseigner à
domicile le bras de fer avec l'Éducation
nationale et loin d'être terminé